[Music]
so
hello and welcome to crosstalk where all
things are considered i'm peter lovell
who is the fascist well given the state
of our politics the fascist
is your political opponent even mortal
enemy
tragically and dangerously the term
fascist is more times than not a
political slur
to destroy someone's character fascism
is an odious ideology and political
practice
we all should be careful when
referencing it
[Music]
crosstalking fascism i'm joined by my
guest vladimir goldstein
in providence he's the chair of the
department of slavic studies at brown
university
and in budapest we cross to george
samueli
he is a podcaster at the gaggle which
can be found on youtube
rumble and locals all right gentlemen
crosstalk rules in effect that means you
can jump anytime you want and i always
appreciate it let's go to vladimir first
vladimir i'm very glad to have you and
george on the program to talk about this
very important topic
because being a trained academic
historian in modern european and russian
history
and still dabble in it because i get to
talk to a very interesting people like
yourself and george on this program
i'm very disturbed in mainstream media
and in
um um you know political diatribe so
that people use the term
fascist it's a very important term it's
very dangerous term
i think we have to use a lot of
precision when using it because if you
don't
you miminize the the the the fascist
experience that was in the 20th century
and what could possibly
happen in the future so give your
reflection here i mean i'm sure you hear
the same things i hear how do you feel
when you hear
he's a fascist she's a fascist go ahead
yeah i think you know it's a
double-edged sword and it's
in it's dangerous and both of its
ramifications first of all
this tendency to demonize your opponent
and call them a fascist is not very good
but by using it by cheapening the term
we actually
run a risk of missing the fascist
fascist
faces which can appear in our midst that
is you know there is a definitely
elements of cultural political mentality
which eventually you know results in
certain actions
which can be called fascists but this
term you know as you said
have to be used very concretely it
should be analyzed
because you know i for example in the
movement which we've seen in
in the united states in the west what
they call themselves antifa
and their fascist you know there's a lot
of f f
fascists kind of thinking in what an
action in what they're doing so we
really have to be very careful
how when what you use and i think it's
very important to come back to the terms
and understand what's what's behind it
you know george
same question to you um because it's
overuse makes it meaningless and that's
what i find
terrifying as i stressed in my
introduction my first question to
vladimir
it is a very odious ideology and if we
don't keep tabs on it in the right way
then it can be applied to anything and
if it can be applied to anything it
doesn't mean anything
go ahead george that's exactly right
um i think that if we think about
what is fascism i mean fascism is
obviously
a political movement or a series of
political movements
that arose in the aftermath of world war
one
and came in response to the collapse of
several of the european empires the
collapse of the states
economic dislocation and then you know
all the rest the great inflation in
germany the great depression and so on
so
the fascism has to be located in a
particular historical
uh phenomenon and uh
and when look even within that that
phenomenon
there were wide varieties that's right
i mean hitler was may have been an ally
of mussolini's but mussolini's fascism
was very different from
national socialism uh and that in turn
franco franco was in turn very different
um
from party um so
if you have to somehow really find
define
really what aspects of these movements
are common and then
you know to extend it into the future
what is it
that we we find dangerous and
threatening
about any possible revivals of fascism
and i think when
vladimir mentioned antifa
uh and of course black lives matter i
think there you can see
the the parallels between that that
fascism phenomenon of 100 years ago
namely the resort to political violence
and name of an ideology
and the opportunism of supposedly
democratic politicians to use street
mobs in order to achieve their political
goals
and i think that's a kind of a sinister
legacy of
the fascist movements of those times i
think you bring up
such a fantastic point because you know
the way the term is used today in the
mainstream
it it has some kind of singular meaning
or conjures up an
image or something like that and that's
simply not true that is
a historical here because i mean it's
it's quite
fashionable and i can understand because
of the cold war
is that you know fascism is the right
and then communism is the left here
but you know and you can make that
argument and that's fine but i don't
think it's
satisfactory at the same time vladimir
because it it's it's not really
left or right and george picked up on it
already
it's uh a set of political practices
okay and i think that and and i think in
it it's very um
astute on the on the left to say oh this
that fascism is a rightist phenomenon
and people are the writer that way
but no it's about political practices
and that doesn't have
a political grounding in left or right
maybe what we're finding out is it's
actually in the center
go ahead vladimir yeah i would say
besides political dimension
what we have to stress is certain kind
of you know
cultural sort of movement you know on
many levels
fascism you know we have to define it
and then to understand what it's not but
you know the way
many historians and theoreticians of
fashion
you know observe nowadays is this is a
cultural kind of phenomenon
which somehow privileges certain certain
kind of way of thinking
it's it's it posed some kind of
happiness
in joy utopian joy mythical you know
harmony in the past it projects it in
the future
but right now here in the present there
is some kind of obstacle
you know and that's the case it was
clear you know great
uh right third right ahead and jews and
you know communists are against that
but but you know we can move along and
we see the same pattern
repeated again and again and again in
this movement for example calling trump
a fascist
and calling him kind of a bad guy we
recognize that you know
for many people say among liberal
democrat democrats in the united states
there was great under obama there will
be great
you know fantastic you know under biden
once we got rid of this trump this mean
obstacle and those who helped him this
is the same time mentality
it just can be seen again and again and
again you know in the united states
they have this concept of war whoa are
people who know who see this mythical
kind of nonsense
of the past and the future and aware of
you know like
now if only we got rid of this
dismal legacy of white man everything
will be cool
you know there were like some others you
know in ukraine for example after 2014
they came
up with a similar concept svidoma and
sudome like those who
kind of know they're aware so they are
aware of
bad legacy of russia which once we get
rid of will bring it up
you know after evolution in soviet union
there was always political correctness
thinking if phone never got the lead of
impurities but this is just basically
very simplistic manikin uh
kind of a way of looking at the world
based on myths not on reality
and it's also kind of pretends to know
that we're like whoa
i will walk now i know and this is just
you know it's philosophically it's weak
it's religiously it's kind of satanic
culturally it's primitive but i think we
see it again and again in all forms
yeah and it's it's a completely
exclusionary either you
know and if you don't know you're not
part of the in-group
knowing and this is what it makes very
exclusionary and very dangerous as i
said in my introduction
you can they end up being your mortal
enemies okay because you you don't
know the truth here you know george it
was brought up here you know this kind
of mythical past
but i think a modern version of 21st
version of it is to destroy the past
because the only way you can have a
present that is it
is acceptable and a a a a future that
you want you must completely obliterate
the past
well we've seen this historically tried
over and over again and it never ends
in a good place and this is being done
what i would say
on the left go ahead george well that is
an excellent point peter because
what most people uh have
traditionally uh not understood that
what we term
fascists is really a dynamic
aggressive culturally uh nihilistic
uh phenomenon and yet people have always
confused that
with conservatism clerical conservatism
i mean even as i mentioned earlier you
know people thought referred to
horti as a fascist forty was a clerical
conservative same with franco clerical
conservatives
i mean even if they had fascist allies
and so
what you talked about the uh the these
mobs in the street
who tear down statues who tear down uh
history
and who uh you know just see or see uh
tradition as just simply a relic that
needs to be swept away
that that is goes to the heart of
fascism because that
that is exactly what was the mentality
of
hitler hitler you know wasn't a
conservative he had absolutely no
interest at
all in uh german history or german
culture
uh he was a nihilist and his the mobs
uh that he unleashed uh to burn books
that yeah that you know there you see
the parallels between the mobs that were
tearing down statues
uh last year and who go around today
uh tyrannizing universities we're saying
oh this is
a white supremacy uh this is uh
white imperialism this is anglo-saxon
political tradition which means it is
just
slavery and the oppression of the uh
colored people by the white man
so let's just discard quality the the
george
the interesting thing for me and
watching all this you know um
uh changing names of libraries taking
down statues
how can anyone explain to me how does
that end systemic racism when you take a
statue away how does that
how does how does it solve their
perceived problem go ahead george before
we go to the break
well of course it doesn't it does um and
yeah
and it's really just a matter of uh you
know terrorizing
uh the public into accepting your
tyranny
hey you know you oppose us because of
course you're uh
a defender of uh tradition you're a
defender of white supremacy
you're a defender of imperialism you're
you're well jordan
we're gonna have to jump in here we're
gonna go to a break here but you you
mentioned the right word you're
terrorized for it okay
uh we're i'm gonna jump in here we're
gonna go to a short break and after that
short break we'll continue more
discussion on fascism stay with rt
welcome back to crosstalk where all
things are considered i'm peter level to
remind you we're discussing fascism
[Music]
okay let's go back to vladimir vladimir
in the first part of the program we
discussed the varieties
of what could be described as fascist
movements fascist ideas
fascist practices here um and now we can
and
you brought it up so i'm going to go
back to you on it this whole phenomenon
of wokism
and it's exclusively focused on race
um and it's coming from what i think
fair to say from
the left here and it's completely
self-referential because
um you there's nothing you can do about
your your the color of um your skin
you're you're just
born that way okay and this is so
there's no
in this kind of wokest um uh uh
ideology there is no redemption because
you were born an oppressor
i mean that is such a self-referential
ideology
and george used the word at the very end
of the first part of the program
it terrorizes you go ahead vladimir yeah
you know first of all it's based not on
you know on reality not on a serious
analysis of kind of historical
circumstances but on some kind of
musical thinking that you know say you
know wookies now
hate with all their might uh columbus
you know imagining as if like the life
uh
on these shores here was totally ideal
be in latin america under myers or
stackers
you know yeah and and over then the bad
white man
showed up and once we got rid of his
impact everything were fine and dandy
but as i said this is a pattern of kind
of fascist
thinking that you know mythical past
utopian future
and some kind of obstacle group and we
know like if if we
if it you know i mentioned aesthetics
and mice you know when when they
saw their threat the danger coming from
spaniards
what would they do they came up with
this idea of sacrificing thousands of
people
ripping their hats out hoping to to find
a solution
they didn't find the solution this is
this is destructive terrorizing
vicious which is way rather than sort of
working all together towards some kind
of you know meaningful
historically based you know solution it
it's target somebody
uh who needs to sacrifice destroy this
amok that
and you know this is so destructive
ultimately and we've seen it being
repeated again and again
this this target in scapegoating some
kind of group and hoping by
eliminating it will get somewhere this
is this is
ultimately fashion but i would add one
more thing the danger in all this
and i think the situation with aztecs is
very typical
that high priests intellectuals you know
educated people who are participating in
it oh yeah
when just crowd screams and yells you
know down with this down with that it's
one thing
but intellectuals would say guys let's
look at things historically let's
let's acknowledge we don't know the
truth let's
let's be humble no nowadays
intellectuals kind of
feed it feed it with kind of have baked
theories
feed it with kind of more more
information about like abusers of
whoever they want to accuse so that's a
very dangerous phenomenon so so
other intellectuals who my challenges
are silenced threatened
accused or or demonized
consequently we don't have a dialogue
and you know it it leads up to violence
yeah well they're cowards it's yeah they
just say it they're cowards all right
it's a professional managerial class
that legitimize this here
you know you know george i don't want to
go down this rabbit hole too deep here
but you know let's look at the
issue of of racism and and slavery and
reparations i mean in if you look at you
know white people didn't
invent slavery white people were
enslaved alt
all through history okay and the
historical fact is that it was
white people that ended slavery as we
know it today in the world
almost completely eradicated it still
does exist in some pockets
but it was it was uh and i have to give
the the english the
credit you know they said this is not
good we're going to use our our vast sea
power we're going to start hounding
these people to destroy this trade i
mean
and that happened over the last few
hundred years from time immemorial there
has been
slavery but you listen to these locusts
walking around it
it's something that's been around for
300 years i mean it's so ahistorical
and it's cynical go ahead george well
exactly right uh and in fact um
the um the colored people are not the
only ones who have been
uh enslaved and as you say slavery has
been
around since the beginning of time and
you know i mean
to talk about philosophy remember the uh
the great um
hegel's philosophy revolved around the
master slave dialectic
because he said that a crucial moment
in the uh the growth of
self-consciousness of man in other words
slavery was just when part and parcel of
war
and the you're the enslavement of a
conqueror of the conqueror so
there's nothing at all that this is oh
uniquely whites against the
colored people but what's really
happening now
is that this a historical attitude the
destruction of
people's lives and careers if they
refuse
to follow a cult because what we have
not this black lives matter
is a cult and he demands kind of the uh
obese just as you know the uh the
fascist leaders of the past required
obesity so if you if you follow uh say
uh football in uh in the united kingdom
before every single match
every single day uh all of the players
have to sit and take the knee
and no one has any choice on it no one
says well i don't really see why we have
to take a knee for this organization
black lives matter i mean i you know
there's a lot of very
uh unsavory aspects of this organization
no
everybody has to take the need and if
you don't take the knee you can feel
the wrath of uh of the
sporting authorities and then so you see
this
throughout the culture then people uh uh
you know express some skepticism and say
well you know
why why you know why why do i have to
accept this idea
well you you do have to because if you
don't
you will lose uh your position and worse
you know there's also the criminal
penalties that might come
down the pipe uh because you know you
know
you might be deemed uh engaging in hate
speech
and so then you you the authorities so
you can see how this mentality
now melts together with the state and to
create also punishments
of those who don't follow uh you know
the
correct ideological doctrine yeah and it
obviously creates a chilling effect okay
you do
you don't want to express an opinion
because you don't want the wrath
of these people here you know vladimir
george you know i'm going to date us
okay on this program here i have to
admit i was
very interested in the frankfurt school
the critical theory i mean
i i read about it was very very
interesting to me
it was a a new iteration of marxism
basically putting in culture and taking
out race here
i never thought it would be a user's
manual i guess that's what really caught
me off guard here
vladimir talked about that there because
this is
you know and i'm not just saying this is
it's marxism no no this is what we call
the in the in the literature
western marxism the frankfurt school
many of their members
came to the united states during uh and
after the second world war
and became very influential thinkers
okay there's a man named martin j
he's written a wonderful book about it
if you want to read about it i think
it's called the dialectical imagination
fascinating book i've read it a number
of times but like i said i didn't
take it as a user's manual it was
actually a warning
for me go ahead vladimir yeah
unfortunately you know we basically do
have to go back to the roots and i
i believe you know that economics lies
at the foundation of many things and
improvement of human life is fundamental
and substituted
all that with some kind of uh new kind
of shibboleth some
identity politics or or any kind of
fashion
it's nearsighted so maybe it's easier to
do
you know it's much easier to introduce
some kind of new legislature than
to change economics and and make you
know everybody
partake of say economic pie that's why a
lot of intellectuals fall
for that it's much easier to push it but
you know
in in in reference to our previous
discussion of slavery i would say
here we have like obama and hillary
clinton champions of
walkisms and they are trying to do that
so what
actually they accomplished for example
in situations like libya
they bombed it into sort of non-existent
blaming the tyre and whatever right now
we have endless report and in libya they
actually now
have a slave market now libya is
destroyed where and now they bring
slaves
so that's a that's a very paradoxical
result of this kind of
very myopic application of some kind of
you know pseudo concept of equality
when you think that you know qadhafi is
a bad guy and you want to introduce some
kind of equality
you end up destroying any government
structures and now
there are gangs of people selling you
know enslaved people
the same black people for whom they're
fighting so this is a paradox and you
know
you cannot take the whole this this
project seriously honestly
yeah i mean george i mean absolutely i
mean they don't
i mean this is just one gross form of
virtue signaling
because it's really people you know it's
kind of white liberal suburbanites you
know
professional managerial class that push
this here uh
they they uh donate money like as it
kind of somehow absolves them of their
collective guilt which i thought we
were supposed to believe in collective
guilt okay and then they just kind of
walk away from it and
it's for me it's kind of like these
people they go into a room they they
take the pin out of the grenade they
toss it and then they leave the room i
mean there's not much downside for them
but everybody else gets the shrapnel go
ahead george
yes yes exactly uh and of course
uh it's it's much worse than just
paradox i mean
there's a a rather sinister agenda to it
because
uh the people with these slogans
specially especially fascists
they move into uh ukraine and align
themselves with
those who actually react
uh and by claiming that it's the
russians uh who are the fascists
the same thing of course happened uh in
yugoslavia
where the serbs led by milosevic who
actually wanted to maintain
the multinational uh
multi-denominational
yugoslavia wanted to keep it going they
were dubbed the fascist
whereas the fascist apologist the
mustache
apologist in croatia were teaching the
democrats
so it's all of this is a kind of there's
a very sinister game that is being
played
and again we look at uh you know obama
played a terrible role in all of this i
mean what he did domestically how he
used this
uh slogan and demonizing his political
opponents with
by with this racist uh fascist but you
know
look at again what what he did in syria
where he
you know in a very cynical way aligned
himself
with with the people who are exactly
racist who are
complete oppressors you know whether
it's oppressors of uh
and george we can add to that we can add
to that
every single year waffen-ss units
you know they commemorate um the
collaboration with the nazis in ukraine
and in
baltic republics the state department
tony blinken where are you
i thought you were all about you know
norms okay and
values they never say anything about it
it's like a little cultural oddity for
these people here
all right gentlemen that's all the time
we've had fascinating discussion here i
want to thank my guests in providence
and in budapest and i want to thank our
viewers for watching us here at rt see
you next time and remember
crosstalk rules